okay moving on now
to another observation
a lot of people have trouble with the
skis
they also have trouble with the Foster
bury when they're they come they cut
and because they're they're trying to
cut and make it feel the same as the the
other suburbers they've kind of feel
Twisted out it's sometimes puts this
cane line out of the body
it should
the same straight feeling
of coming forward
should stay
on here
it shouldn't be remembered from the
other film it shouldn't be
twisting twisting you should be pelvis
tipping
difficult twisting
not twisting
of course it puts the line
following the cane
outside the body he's been inside the
body
so therefore the hips need to be more
straight and the pelvis tip
Edge
knee
I'm going forward so why would I go
forward so why would I
twist
what's the pen if I
tourists
the plane is going this way
and yet I'm going forward so I'm not
going with the universe am I I'm trying
to sort of go one way with the universe
and another way with the intervention
that would rip the universe in half so
to be one with the universe so it says
he put it we must
all right
okay nope
not too much of this
I can't tip
to cut tip
cut
two
notice the heel
couch
okay when you kill lands that should be
there in the cap well that's that's
that's that's my way of doing it I'm not
saying it's the others I hate me
oh hey hey
so
that's mainly the fourth to bury and I
said I'd leave them to light her back
the weaknesses why you wouldn't use the
hips in a circle manner but the pelvis
tip
pelvis tip as I said earlier I'm just
putting it in conjunction with
Suburbia it's the first suburi just on
the light right and the left sides
thank you for your time
then go on to the thrusts